another thing when i was up there is
i don't want you guys to make fun of me
or
judge me or ridicule me or of any or
anything but
i'm thinking about doing something to
myself i'm getting
operation cosmetic cosmetic get out of
here you know what i'm going to do
and i'm not even [ __ ] around he's not
joking i'm not joking around
a tummy tuck i don't know
what are you i'm sorry what
i have no idea what you're saying right
now i don't know what i said all right
all right
but guess what it is you can
ask guess first yeah beard implants
yeah yes [ __ ] how did you feel
a good guess without
yeah beard implants see that he put the
connection yeah
i need a beard yes has it affected your
career
it no has not affected my career but it
will affect his career
i know i one day they're gonna make the
movie of paul bunyan and
i need will you laugh with that i need
to [ __ ] be able to audition at least
i need to be in the money i need to be
the running i need to be the running i
need to be in the running dude
you have you ever seen me with an axe no
they're the end
i'm a i kill it in axe acting yeah yeah
it doing it no oh yeah yeah and i'm
gonna do it well i just said on the
podcast so people will know but i'm
gonna do it so that people
that has that hasn't listened to this
podcast
will go oh that looks natural but he's
gonna want like patches on them so
you're trying to try rogaine first you
can't put rogaine on your face like that
why don't you try latisse for your
eyelashes you can grow hair anywhere in
your face
what's latish i don't know that this is
like for your eye it used to be used for
like glaucoma patients yeah
to like release like ocular pressure i
think and then when people use it
elsewhere around the eye random hair
started to grow and that's how they
discovered that
oh [ __ ] you can also use it on your
eyelashes and to extend them
you can use it on your eyebrows too how
come people don't use it
on their like because it's a different
type of hair so your eyebrows i don't
want that kind of hair i don't want
eyelash hair on my face
i don't want a beard that looks like
eyelashes
they'll go you know they'll go up
they'll go up and then also i'll just
walk into parties and it'll just be
[ __ ] people will laugh at me
and i don't want those i want a real
beard where people go god bobby looks
like a man
yeah you do look like a man no i need i
need a beard
what was the inspiration i don't know i
just go i i can't
well if the thought came things i cannot
do
oh so what else is every month oh so
many different things
i cannot do um i can't swim
you can swim barely though can't do a
layup i can't do a layout
for sure not lay up definitely can't
even shoot i can't ollie
no ollie like an old escape but you know
what he can do what axe
is
but anyway um so what it they take the
hairs from the back of your head
right here the ones in the neck part
yeah like they do the you know the
the head surgery part the regular and
then they infuse them under your face
and then
they fall out and then they grow back in
my would you really be okay for the rest
of your life
having to trim and worry about a beard
and food getting there and
would you said that before food as if i
have a problem eating
it won't do you just have food on your
cheeks just on my [ __ ] in my beard
bobby you have a [ __ ] pepperoni pizza
in your beard oops oops
one time one time i made out with a guy
with like a really like thick facial
hair yeah
and it smelled like old rice yeah
because he doesn't have lips
and that's why he grew his beard out he
doesn't know how to chew or something
i already know how to use my mouth i
know to hold it in
i know how to swallow and all that with
your four teeth
all right well you know what you have to
bring up the insides of my mouth why
don't you get your teeth fixed before
you put
a beard on you how about my teeth are
fine i've been begging him to go see the
dentist no
you've never been yeah i've been to the
dentist
yeah [ __ ] been there dude what's
wrong i [ __ ] came
you know what i said to myself i was
gonna be nice to everyone
and i was going to like appreciate you
right do that whole thing and then all
of a sudden i just feel
conflict bro you feel attacked i feel
attacked a little bit man i just need a
little support right now we need to
support his dreams [ __ ] it let's get it
get it done when are you gonna do it
tomorrow let's do it tomorrow no no no i
need to
i need to find first of all the best guy
to do it i don't know who that is i'm
sure plenty in beverly hills
number two um i'm gonna do it so that
it's not full-blown like there's kind of
blotchy why do you want blotchy
because i don't want it to be completely
perfect because the people will know
yeah they will know yes but with asians
i've seen some online
where it's like they're a little bit
here maybe a little bit up in the cheek
yeah not not too yeah you know blotchy
are you gonna regret having okay when
you actually shave it
yeah you get the razor burn and then the
bumps and then the acne
men it's not as it's not as easy as you
think it's it's a lot of maintenance
[ __ ] acne you know i have acne i've i've
struggled with acne all my [ __ ]
razor burns razor bumps [ __ ] razor bro
right i i
so i'm used to bumps on my face okay
i was doing research for the paul bunyan
movie and i was out in the forest what
does bobby lee do by uh
attack my face my point is is this i'm
definitely gonna get done i don't know
when
i i think i'm gonna get it done if don't
let people know so that it can just one
day be like
natural yeah yeah right yeah you know
what you're right
i'm never going to mention it again you
shouldn't have mentioned it to begin
with i should i [ __ ] up
yeah but i think people will forget yeah
and i think
when i get it done 10 years from now i
think people will completely forget like
what's his name
and then they'll go ask me just i'm
sorry for interrupting baby but ask me
about my ten years from now hey man i
didn't notice you had a full beard
yeah i you know i've been shaving all my
life dude but
you know i just decided yeah with
harry's razor with harry potter
the best razor in the business are they
are we still sponsoring them yeah
harry's razor
the best razor in the whole wide world